Океани і гори, відомі світові столиці
й безмежні простори заповідних територій.
В умовах пандемії і зупиненого міжнародного авіасполучення
місця, зняті тревелблогеркою
Яною Метьолкіною,
виглядають ще більше недосяжними.
Дівчина відвідала вже понад 50 країн.
Із послабленням карантину та наближенням літа Яна,
як і мільйони інших українців, знову
задумалася над цілями для літнього відпочинку.
Цього року тревелблогерка планує
провести його не менш яскраво,
але - подорожуючи Україною.
Я не дуже сильно раджу от прямо
цим літом вже кудись їхати.
Треба досліджувати нові жанри:
хайкінг, трекінг, природа.
Я думаю, що зараз зміниться взагалі наше сприйняття,
ми не будемо хотіти у великі міста,
у великі якісь лакшері-готелі,
тому що там дуже багато людей,
дуже багато небезпеки.
Тому оці подорожі, як поїздки
на джипах по бездоріжжю,
гарні будиночки на природі, на це літо -
це найкращий варіант.
З точки зору безпеки, оптимальним видом відпочинку
в цьому туристичному сезоні може стати еко-туризм.
Починаючи з 12 травня, уряд дозволив українцям
відвідувати парки, в тому числі й національні.
Їх в Україні - аж 52, а ще - понад 20
природніх та біосферних заповідників.
Однак організатори еко-відпочинку переконані:
очікувати буму туристів там можна тільки за умови
відновлення транспортного
сполучення між регіонами.
В уряді поки взагалі не говорять про повноцінну роботу залізниці -
лише прогнозують, що частково перевезення
можуть відновитися в червні-липні.
У гіршому варіанті, якщо
не буде залізничних перевезень,
то просто будемо рекомендувати людям приїжджати власним транспортом
в такі осередки екологічного туризму,
де навколо щось можна подивитися: чи то Карпати, чи то устя Дунаю
чи Арабатська стрілка.
І вже на місці організовувати екскурсії -
чи то індивідуальні, чи то маленькими групами
по 7-8 учасників з дотриманням правил безпеки - вони цілком можливі.
Люди готові їхати хоч вже, тому що люди засиділися,
люди активні, вони хочуть
на природу, хочуть відпочивати,
бачити один одного, спілкуватися один з одним.
За підрахунками Міністерства культури
та інформаційної політики,
через карантинні обмеження туристична
галузь України вже втратила
близько півтора мільярда доларів,
і, за прогнозами експертів,
збитки й далі зростатимуть.
Тому велику надію галузь покладає на українців, які цього року
віддадуть перевагу внутрішньому туризму.
Однак після більш як двох місяців карантину
думки українців щодо
формату відпочинку розділилися.
Літо завжди проводимо на морі,
в різних країнах, тому будемо їхати,
тому що життя треба жити,
а не відкладати на потім.
Остраху немає однозначно. В Україні ми
дуже класно провели час минулого року в Одесі.
Тому туди можна поїхати або в Карпати
У нас чудова країна.
Можна розглядати будь-що:
і гори, і моря, і річки.
Ми, мабуть, будемо в селі, під Богуславом,
там у нас є будиночок,
там будемо відпочивати.
Бо боїшся за дітей. Мені, мабуть, спокійніше,
коли я вивіз сім'ю, і там вони вже
бігають, дихають повітрям.
Однією з найважливіших перепон, що може завадити відновленню туристичної активності,
є обмеження в роботі готелів і закладів харчування.
І якщо ресторани й кафе вже принаймні приймають гостей на літніх майданчиках
і готують страви на виніс, то готелі досі офіційно під забороною.
Запрацювати вони зможуть тільки, дотримуючись протоколів безпеки.
Над їхньою розробкою нині спільно з профільними організаціями
працює Державне агентство з туризму.
Готелям як мінімум необхідно виконати декілька таких речей,
які про це будуть говорити саме споживачу,
а саме це дистанціювання,
уникнення черг на рецепції,
по можливості зробити он-лайн чекін.
Має бути аптечка, має бути захищений персонал,
має бути дезінфекція постійна поверхонь,
приміщень або кварцування.
А от садиби і котеджі в Карпатах
вже активно бронюються туристами.
Це стосується і морських курортів.
Попри значні фінансові втрати, у травні
з новинами про послаблення карантину почалися перші бронювання.
Власниця комплексу відпочинку на Херсонщині Олена
каже, що їй пощастило з форматом закладу,
адже кожен номер має окремий вихід, територія велика,
бунгало на пляжі розміщені на відстані одне від одного
і є ще й місце для кемпінгу.
Тому нині комплекс користується попитом.
Бронюють нині в нас на великий термін.
Тобто це не тиждень,
не 5 днів,
як спостерігалося в попередніх сезонах,
а бронюють місяць, два, три.
Минулими роками вже в лютому місяці
була бронь на серпень
і на другу половину липня.
У цьому році серпень ще трохи вільний,
бо я думаю, хтось там ще планує за кордон і тому подібне.
Тим часом європейські країни, особливо ті, чий економічний добробут
суттєво залежить від туризму, вже розмірковують над початком сезону відпусток.
У ЄС обговорюють так звані туристичні коридори між окремими країнами,
яким вдалося стримати масове розповсюдження коронавірусу.
У ЄС також працюють над розробкою єдиних протоколів безпеки для курортів
та навіть паспортів здоров’я для туристів,
аби переміщення людей між країнами не спровокували
нову хвилю розповсюдження коронавірусу.
До прикладу, у Туреччині заповнюватимуть будуть не всі номери,
шезлонги на пляжі стоятимуть на дистанції 1,5-2 метри,
спа та спортивні центри будуть зачиненими,
а харчування за системою all-inclusive обслуговуватимуть офіціанти.
На думку власниці туристичної агенції, відпочинок українців за кордоном
цього літа теж може
стати можливим за певних умов.
Багато європейських країн -
та сама Греція, Кіпр,
Португалія - планують
відкритися з початку липня.
Все впирається в те, що немає повноцінного авіасполучення.
Тому, можливо, наші туроператори домовляться про деякі чартерні рейси,
наприклад, у Туреччину.
Все-таки на липень деякі оптимістичні прогнози є.
Якщо, не дай Бог, станеться так, що будуть ці напрямки закриті,
то в людей не буде іншого виходу, як все-таки відпочивати в Україні.
Але на заваді те,
що може не сподобатися, звісно,
це дуже слабенька інфраструктура, відсутність доріг і високі ціни.
На заваді повноцінній відпустці цього літа окрім обмежень і загроз,
пов’язаних з пандемією короновірусу, - ще й економічні чинники.
За результатами соцопитувань, лише за перший місяць карантину
фінансова ситуація погіршилися у двох третин українців.
Тому поїздки Україною чи подорожі за кордон
для багатьох стануть не доступними.
Альтернативою на літо для українців, що живуть у містах,
могли б стати будиночки у передмісті.
Але попит на них вже спровокував значне підвищення цін на оренду.
Тепер місяць перебування на дачі під Києвом
коштує дорожче, ніж відпустка в Європі до карантину.